every single day three times a day we
vote for the world we want to live in by
what we choose to put on our plate
[Music]
since our launch together we have made a
resounding statement for the positive
better world we want to foster for
ourselves
and future generations by choosing
plants
thank you for being a part of meaningful
change and together
let's help create a brighter world
invite a friend
include a family and light the path for
more health
love and compassion the plant power meal
planner
customized recipes shopping list grocery
delivery
in every metropolitan area everything
you need
to finally master your nutrition